So since studying your work,
one of the things that I
find most fascinating is
your analysis of the story of
Cain and Abel.
And my question is,
um,
if,
if came got to the point
that he did right before,
uh,
killing his brother,
murdering his ideal and decided that
that was something he didn't want to do,
what advice or guidance would you,
would you give a person
that got to that point?
Well,
there's a story I read
called the cocktail party.
I've mentioned this before by Tsa Elliot.
In the cocktail party,
there's a scene,
it's a play where this woman approaches
a psychiatrist and starts talking to him
about her problems.
And she said something that surprises him.
She says,
I hope that I'm the problem.
And he says,
well,
why would you hope that?
And she says,
well,
I thought about it a lot.
And if the world's the problem,
then I'm done because I
can't change the world.
But if I'm the problem,
then maybe there's something
about myself I can change.
I can undo this terrible
situation that I meant.
And so I would say that's repentance.
Fundamentally.
It's like there if,
and I say this carefully
because I understand that
people are susceptible to bad
fortune.
Sin and ignorance can make that worse,
but independently of that
like good people suffer.
Make no mistake about it,
but if things aren't right for you,
if you're resentful about being,
because that's the right way of cause,
that's the deepest way of thinking about
if you read the writings of the people
who do the mass killings for example,
that's what you see over and over.
It's cane.
It's like they're angry
beyond comprehension at the
intolerability of being and
they're angry at God.
Even if they don't say
it exactly like that.
They come so close to saying it like that,
that it's,
there's no difference.
You know what God says to Cain is look
to yourself first before you criticize
being,
and that strikes me is right.
It's because to not do that as arrogant
beyond belief that say tannic arrogance.
Literally,
if something like that can be literal,
it's like don't make yourself the judge
of being before you clean up your your
room,
let's say.
And it because,
and the other thing too,
this is something I learned in some
part from soldier Nixon when he,
when he was in the prison camps and trying
to understand how these heroic people
he saw could possibly manage it.
One of the exercises he undertook,
and he really viewed this within Christian
Orthodox context of Repentance and
redemption,
is he said he went over his life with a
fine tooth comb and tried to imagine all
of the ethical mistakes he made in his
entire life that he knew were mistakes,
right?
Hey,
there was,
it was this was a soul search,
not,
he wasn't relying on external standards
of morality except in so far as we're
inevitably influenced by those.
And then his idea was,
is there something I could do
right now to put that right?
And that's the right question.
Like if things aren't going your way,
and I think that means that you're
resentful and arrogant and deceitful.
Those are the three things
that clump together.
I think that that,
that constitute the core of evil.
It's something like that.
And so if you're possessed by that,
which is a hell,
then it's repentance.
That's the right answer.
And what that means is you have to figure
out what you did wrong and you have to
pay for it.
And then at least you could think,
well look,
I can try that with all of my soul,
let's say,
and see what happens,
right?
It could at least be an experiment.
And then I would also say
that that's an act of faith.
It's an act of faith to conduct that
experiment because you put yourself on the
line,
right?
And that's what an act of faith is.
You don't know the outcome,
but you don't know the
outcome of your life.
So to live in some senses,
an act of faith.
You're putting faith in something
that that's why you're moving forward.
You couldn't move forward
without an act of faith,
you know?
And people say,
well,
I only move forward on
the basis of the fact.
It's like,
yeah,
but you select the fact and there's an
infinity of facts and they don't just
tell you what to do.
So it's not a credible answer.
So if you're in that situation,
it's like,
look to yourself,
you know?
And,
and one of the things about soldier
that's a bloody amazing is that's what he
did.
And then he wrote the Gulag
archipelago and you know,
he took an ax to the intellectual
and moral substructure of,
of the totalitarian communist states.
So while he was redeeming himself,
let's say he was simultaneously
redeeming the world,
and you know,
you see something like that,
like you,
you got to wake up,
man.
That's,
that was really something.